33-й
найхожий був не було нічого не їсти
вмирали по хатах Діти
там лежить ніхто не думав що то вона
буде те война таке пережили ми та й
голови холодали вже пам'ять мучимося жду
Я її хочу дождаться це і Перемоги
Я родилася в пустельниках п'ятеро нас
росло і були б трошки старші А мені було
що 13 років
я не могла я нікуди не ходила Не в мене
ноги були
сама не могла родить а вона вже були
коні вдома
корова була
забирали все в колгос
плуги вози геть усе
од людей а там уже розводили цей колгосп
а тоді якось що воно стався Цей голод Не
було нічого не їсти багато померло дітей
і таких у людей
[музика]
брати
такі були трохи ворушилися пішли на
яремківщину хотіли бараків взяти Ну
вирвати того з землі щоб був чай
солодкий і потерти на якогось спекти
коржика там Липи нарвали кропиви нарвали
нас сушили натерли його оце пересушив
перетерли туди трошки того то такий
пекли але вони не не дойшли вони йшли на
той єрепівщину а там їхав облєщик і
михалка зловив і забрав її роботу дуже
крепко побили його у його в голові геть
голова була розбита
[сміх]
здихали корови у колгоспі бо не було
пастухів ніхто не пасть корів то нехай
ті корови а там Так у нас було туди далі
таке кладьби Що це корінне
вони туди привезли з тих корів людей
стоїть багато щоб темнять воно ж не не
травняне нічого Це ж воно здохло до
голоду так як Люди здихали вмирали ми от
голоду так і корови
просять дядьку не лийте а там якесь таке
було у бутилочках криволін називалася і
вони облили цей цю корову тако розрізали
посередині і поналивали цього криволіну
ті люди спішать трошки там там є
урізали
поприносили хто поварив то ти померли
всі що пооділити м'ясо
[музика]
можна було знайти
пшениці трошки в колгоспі то другі Люди
там сіяли на городах то мали то
приходили і вона жодна велика
два камінці здорові і йде на другому
тако лежить і дірочка тут ось цей
тиждень
набереш крупи варять суп а то на муку то
роблять такі Ну вони блінчики чи щось
таке спечеш щоб воно можна було поїсти
цей Липи і кропиви а трошки пшениці
береш на крупу та такий ріденький суп
варили Тарас похлябаєш поїсти та й лежиш
Ой Боже Боже
да пляшку було але Що зробимо
раз на день їли
трошки якоїсь тупо То мама два ракету
блінчиків на печуть Та так на день поїмо
не так ми жили але пережили все хто
пережив а хто помер
було таке що вмирали по хатах діти а їх
попросили которі такий мужчини живіший
були Бо були такі не дуже ходили добре а
вони прийшли то в хату це на печії вже
Діти там лежить позбирали їх на фуру
поклали яму викопали здорову
Ну там 10 чи скільки дітей усіх ту яму
покидали та позакопували
а тато своїх то сам Заніс сам за ніс так
близенько кладьби ще в нас було то за
ніс старшого цього сина
то закопав плаче та каже Боже щоб мені
хтось сказав що я буду свою дитину
закопувати голову без труни без нічого а
маленьку те Олю 4 года було тоже Заніс а
тако в платтячку в чому лежало там ще
якусь тато вже маму видали хустку
замотали то вже ямку викопали то так
[музика]
до голоду не було що а вже було так і
хліба цього старого не хватило а нового
не дождалися у когось була то візьмеш та
її Те відро картоплі то обирали то щоб
там на тих лушпайках були парасочки
товстило шпальки садили на картоплю щоб
родила отак розводили картоплю
руки були
рвали такі вовки були ноги такі оволи
ходити не можна було тато мене виносили
на двір як сонце то винесуть на двір та
простаять там то я собі там полежу а як
уже
вечером то приходять добирають мене в
хату Та я вже в хаті Лежу а холодно тому
в хаті Лежу не могла ходить геть
Ой та зараз болять ноги і все прийшов до
мене я щось говорю забрали від мене
забрали від мене їжу
постоїмо подивився та каже до мене каже
до мене Що ти вже не хочеш і не їсти а
що забрали от тебе та коло тебе не було
каже нічого у хату та й мамі каже мабуть
наша любов мре кажуть Вже говорить що в
неї вкрали щось позабирали в неї але
вижила І до цієї порижу
[музика]
33-й
найхожий був
а то так ще можна було жити
А так 33 дуже дуже було погано
якось пережили
ніхто нічого не говорили боялися чогось
щоб не посадили по тюрму бо тоді ж так
Ну що сказав Хтось зараз вже заберуть
що почалася війна що Гітлер прийшов на
Україну
сліпий Гітлер прийшов Ну вони били там
десь били вбивали палили трохи ну таке
не робили як ті роблять ті вже мені
стожариють геть усе що є
забрали мене туди в Германію я втекла а
потім прийшла додому Що ж знов давай
будуть брати а я прийшов додому дала нам
вже отакого подерла руки подерла руки
отут подерла груди подерла руту подерла
ножем потрапила солі і посолила
таке поробила такі рани собі
і не такі були шкодливі як ці це вредний
це не вже не люди а хто воно як сказати
це так не робили німці Ні я ж кажу вони
там у селах палили хати а оце тут вже
скрізького геть усіх стало столиці цілий
не було дівчат і дівчат не чіпали як там
дітей мучать жінок
це як це найхожа война та нікому не дай
Бог нікому чому і знав що
дуже тяжко война тяжка
як її пережити
І вам і нам усім нам тяжко з нею з цею
войною там бахкають [ __ ] трав тікать
А куди втікати
підеш туди у той
погрів може завалить там будь на волі
тоже буде горе
я война і ми мучимось і ще онуки пішли
вже на
цей фронт у мене три онуки воюють на
фронті Вітя Рома і Саша ніхто не думав
що то вона буде Ця війна не думали а
прийшла вже на 9 років вже 9-й рік
щоб скоріше кончилося
щоб скоріше ця війна кончилась в тій
люди
поприходили додому
Де мої нитки що я не лузала на фронт
що я не на фронт не лужаю а
солдати мої дорогі люди такі добрі нащо
таке вам горе вот так
будете
хлопці
ховатися і щоб ніхто не побив у вас
А ми будемо це його розплітати а вони
будуть заплітати 9 штук вплели
я розплітала все так сиджу їм
розцвітаю Та кладу а вони беруть та й
плетуть
коли це кончилося то вже не плили ми
його щоб ти Горе мені хлопці не не
бачили його
война скоріше кончилось та й сиджу Та й
думаю
отаке Я думаю більше не хочу нічого
їх геть треба вибити а тоді вже нам буде
добре тільки щоб небо закрить таке
пережили ми та й голод і холодали ще
Покамість мучимося ще пока будемо ждати
по виду чи ні перемогу жду Я її хочу
дождаться це і Перемоги і вип’ю і будуть
співати
Ой у лузі калина похилилася чогось
нашого рідна Україна зажурилася а ми тут
червону калину піднімемо А ми рідну
Україну розвеселимо
[музика]